in the past hour the Indian Prime
Minister Narendra Modi and now it's a
nationwide lockdown which will be
enforced at midnight it will affect 1.3
billion people in the world's second
most populous country more than 500
infections and 10 deaths have been
reported so far but Modi has warned
everybody to stay at home and save
themselves who did they listen carefully
the whole country from today 12:00
midnight the entire country it will be
in a complete lockdown in order to save
India in order to save the citizens of
India and to save yourself save you and
your family today at 12:00 midnight
there will be a total ban of venturing
out of your home every state every
territory every district every village
every locality is being put on lockdown
well let's say and not more now from on
India's lockdown from Elizabeth Burnham
in New Delhi since Thursday evening is
when he first addressed the nation and
he asked everyone to observe this 14 our
voluntary curfew and since then that
voluntary curfew was extended and 75 of
of the country's districts that was 1/10
that happened on Sunday halfway through
the day yesterday on Monday that was
further extended by the end of the day
three quarters of the country was under
some kind of a lockdown and the Prime
Minister came out this evening and
unsurprisingly as more and more of the
country is under some kind of luck
locked down whether its complete or
partial he announced that in fact it is
the entire country that it's for 21 days
and that that is the only way that India
can fight fight coronavirus saying that
you know much more developed nations
have have struggled against it and that
these precautions have to be taken now
if India has any chance of fighting it